understanding I kido Marshall context
part for the specifics of icater
technique so in the last video is a very
averse video we had we talked about what
Marshall context was basically that's
the situation you're going to be in
marshall e speaking in the next video we
talked about MMA and how MMA solved
problems for that situation one on one
unarmed which is the situation we look
at a lot but maybe didn't really answer
all contexts strikes there's a lot of
different contexts in martial arts in
the next video we talked about why what
I kiddo is looking at Nike toes context
is specifically armed situation facing
multiple attackers I mean how that's so
different then unarmed one-on-one that
you really can't compare the two in this
i'm going to give some examples of why
the specifics of the technique you're
different why that matters so if we look
at a very effective unarmed one on one
system like western wrestling there's no
doubt that if you study western
wrestling with in the subdivision of
grappling only in the context of
one-on-one under martial arts you're
going to be a very capable person
there's a lot to learn in that system
that will make you very very effective
one of the strong techniques you'll see
in that would be the double leg takedown
the w take down the magnificent takedown
works very good when you're highly
training it you will get most people on
the ground very effectively and very
quickly the double leg takedown involves
wrapping both your arms around the
person you're attacking the legs and
driving them back so they fall down in
an armed situation this is a poor choice
of technique for example by the knife in
my hand and you came into the double leg
takedown it's still likely you're going
to take me down but when you take me
down you're going to get stabbed for it
probably multiple times and probably
fatally so your takedown cost you
significantly if I have a longer
reaching weapon right like a spear a bow
and arrow a rifle anything like this
you're probably never even get close
enough to meet to effect a double leg
takedown so double leg takedown is not a
very good choice in those arenas of
looking at things so you can see where a
technique like a double leg takedown
which is a strong great technique to use
in a one-on-one unarmed situation isn't
such a great technique when there's
weapons involved another criticism you
see of I kido is there's not a lot of
clinch work in IQ know right so once you
get into a clinch I think it doesn't
have a lot of methods for dealing with
it and this is true we don't and you see
I ghetto people in claim situation they
don't do well right so there's some
videos of Aikido gun and judoka getting
together and doing judo Ron Dory and I
two people don't do very well and this
makes perfect sense because i jus
doesn't do any clinch work Judar does a
lot of clinch work Jude was great at the
clinch I think it was not good at the
clinch so why would you expect an ideal
person to do well in a clinch because of
IQs interest in multiple attackers you
don't see clench work the reasons simple
it's not because clinch work is not
important it's because if we get into a
clinch we're not going to be able to get
out before another person you come in
and hurt us right so when we lose the
autonomy right we get down into the
clinch and start working on the
Reez dealing with one person which is
good in a one-on-one match it opens us
up to be attacked by another person now
this doesn't mean that we cannot be
clinched and that that wouldn't be bad
for a multiple tacker situation what it
means is we spend a lot of time trying
to avoid the clinch so we don't have
throws that come from a clinch situation
we have throws that come pre clinch we
have escapes to keep us from getting
into the clinch so we don't have clinch
escapes too late then but we have pre
clinch escapes we have escapes that are
designed to get us out of a situation
before the clinch even happens and in
just being a foregone conclusion that if
we're clinched it's going to be too late
right so it doesn't matter how good I am
in the clinch it takes too long from a
clinch to deal with multiple attackers
so why it's been a lot of my time
working on the clinch when I'm going to
always be facing multiple attackers
another criticism you see of I kiddo is
why do I canoga spend so much time on
wrist grabs and wrist grab seem like a
very silly attack that doesn't happen
that much it's not a very solid attack
so why do we spend a lot of time with
that what I just said about the pre
clinch applies to that and also another
important factor when we look at weapons
applies to this so if I have a weapon in
my hand if you don't control the weapon
I'm
to use the weapon on you so for example
if you want a box with me and I have a
knife I'm going to use the knife on you
likely even if you're better at hitting
me that I am in hitting you every hit I
make on you is going to be far more
effective than the hits you make on me
right so my strikes with the weapon are
going to be more powerful than your
strikes unarmed so that doesn't mean
that the boxing is not valid what it
means is within our context you you need
to control my weapon hand if you can't
control my weapon hand you're not going
to be a very effective against me so for
me if I have a weapon you grabbing my
wrist is a serious problem the reason
serious problems because now you control
my weapon now every time you hit me I
can't hit you back because you're
controlling my weapon hand so you're
going to hit me I cannot use my weapon I
don't have an advantage anymore so it's
important to learn lots of ways to clear
my weapon hand and use your desire to
hold my weapon against you to trap your
mind with your desire to hold my weapon
and use that against you so these are
just a few specifics and we'll cover
more in other videos later I just want
to give you a few right now so you can
kind of get an idea of why techniques
for one system might not be effective
for another because of our contextual
differences so I hope this helped
clarify marshal context for you why
marshal context is important to
understanding I kido this is going to be
the end of this series hopefully from
here we're going to go on to make a lot
of other videos explaining specifics and
details and help you get squared away
and really help you to understand I
kiddo and what it's trying to do I'm
Krista fine thanks a lot for watching
you